[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux ans je séjourne sur mon grand
père sa passion c'est la chasse je le
vois partir tous les matins avec ses
chiens
un jour il dépose un canard sur la table
de la salle à manger
quelques minutes après le canard a
disparu donc bien sûr que fait mon grand
père il se précipite dans la niche du
chien mais rien de rien il demande à ma
mère à mon oncle à ma grand-mère s'ils
l'ont pris sans succès peut-être le
canard n'était pas mort qui s'est envolé
tout le monde part à sa recherche dans
une grande perplexité
c'est moi qui l'ait pris je le câline je
lui parle je crois qu'il dort je ne veux
plus le lâcher
je ne fais pas de différence entre lui
et moi c'est mon ami un aide que je dois
protéger
je suis sa gardienne car mon premier
instinct c'est d'en prendre soin et de
le cajoler comme une mère ferait avec
son enfant récemment j'ai demandé à ma
mère si elle se souvenait d'un moment
clé qui aurait déclenché cette passion
pour les animaux
elle m'a dit que dès que j'ai eu le
regard posé sur eux
j'ai tout de suite une attitude très
maternante que ce soit vis-à-vis des
mammifères ou des insectes
aussi loin que je m'en souvienne j'ai
toujours ressenti de l'amour pour les
animaux j'ai toujours eu la sensation
d'avoir une mission a réalisé auprès
d'eux donc comme je dis souvent dit aux
personnes qui m'ont interrogé sur mon
orientation scolaire contribuer au
changement de regard que l'humain porte
sur l'animal n'est pas un choix c'est
l'indécence de ma vie cela s'impose à
moi c'est donc cet élan de prendre soin
des animaux qui me pousse naturellement
à faire une licence de biologie puis un
master recherche en éthologie
l'éthologie c'est l'étude du
comportement des espèces
animal je rêve alors d'entrer dans
l'intimité des animaux sauvages en les
observant dans leur milieu naturel
et puis comprend le comportement des
animaux me paraît le meilleur moyen pour
mettre en place des mesures de
conservation efficaces adaptées à chaque
espèce
mais voilà durant la deuxième année de
master je commence déjà à ressentir un
décalage entre ma perception de l'animal
et les discours de mes professeurs
je me rappelle d'un débat sur la
conservation du panda mon prof dit qu'il
vaut mieux tuer tous les pandas restant
plutôt que de mettre de l'argent dans
des mesures de conservation puisque de
toute manière c'est une espèce vous à sa
perte
je n'en croyais pas mes oreilles
c'est donc l'animal est globalement
seulement perçu comme un objet d'étude
que même dans un milieu qui est censé
protéger l'environnement
on accorde peu de valeur à la vie
animale je découvre un rapport trop
froid l'animal un rapport dépourvus de
lien un rapport dépourvu d'émotion et
pourtant l'éthologie est une science qui
étudie le vivant
regardez ce westie là en général on a
deux réactions
oui bon c'est un chien quoi ou au qu'il
est mignon
la majorité des personnes s'arrêtent au
concept chien elle ne voit pas ce qu'il
est elle ne le rencontre qu'à travers
leurs cadres de référence du mot chien
c'est comme si en rencontrant l'un
d'entre vous aujourd'hui je disais oh
c'est un humain catégoriser étiqueté
fait perdre l'expérience du vivant cela
le banalise
moi quand je regarde ce chien je vois
lettre je suis présente à l'expérience
qui se vit en lui et en moi rencontrer
un animal c'est entrer en interaction
avec un autre monde son monde
pour moi chaque individu à un monde qui
lui est propre
or la majorité des personnes ne font pas
la différence entre deux individus de la
même espèce
et vous est-ce que ceux qui ont ou ont
eu un animal de compagnie peuvent lever
la main est ce que pour vous votre
animal est le même qu'un autre individu
de la même race je suppose que non et ce
n'est pas seulement en lien avec les
sentiments que vous avez pour votre
animal mais aussi parce que vous
percevez l'unicité de cet être qui vit à
vos côtés
cette perception de mes animaux de
compagnie je l'appliqué aux animaux
sauvages et aux animaux d'élevage un
loup n'est pas le même qu'un autre loup
une vache n'est pas la même qu une autre
vache chaque être est unique et son
unicité fait son importance revenons à
mon parcours
donc après l'obtention de mon master en
je pars au mexique en tant qu'assistante
de recherche pour étudier le rôle du
hurlement des singes hurleurs au sein de
leur groupe
je passe douze heures par jour dans la
jungle a observé le comportement de ces
singes donc c'est là que je découvre que
ceux ci dans la majorité du temps donc
vont pour pallier l'ennui jeudi le livre
de jonathan safran foer faut-il manger
des animaux
et là tout d'un coup c'est clair pour
moi je suis en train de perdre mon temps
à observer des singes hurleurs en train
de dormir pendant ce temps l'humanité
tue des milliers d'animaux par jour dans
d'atroces conditions et pas seulement
pour se nourrir nous exploitons les
animaux pour des tests cosmétiques
pharmaceutiques et militaires nous le
savons aujourd'hui nomme trop mode de
vie un impact sur tous les écosystèmes
planétaires
nous détruisons des centaines
d'écosystèmes
par l'agriculture intensive la surpêche
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
alors mon urgence à moi c'est de sauver
la planète et changer le monde
j'écoute ma mission je rende darda en
france et je mets fin à ma carrière de
chercheuse je crée en 2013 une
association d'éducation à
l'environnement
je propose des ateliers créatifs et
pédagogiques pour les enfants de 6 à 12
ans pour leur transmettre des valeurs
fondamentales responsabilité liberté
respect et conscience je remarque alors
que beaucoup d'entre eux sont déjà
sensibles à la protection de
l'environnement
l'association démarre bien donc je pars
fin 2014 en australie pour développer le
projet lettre à l'étranger je travaille
nuit des jours d'arrache-pied pour
trouver des partenaires et des pieds
lancement rien ni personne ne
m'empêcherai d'atteindre ma mission
sauver le monde
la vie faisant là bien bien les choses
il ya bien quelqu'un qui s'est imposé
face à cette volonté d'acier est ce
quelqu'un
ce fut moi je prends de manière
inexplicable médicalement 17 kg en
quatre mois
pour moi qui ne prend généralement pas
un kilo se fait un électrochoc
je réalise alors que dans cette mission
et dans cette soif de reconnaissance
je me suis oublié je ne prends pas soin
de moi je ne respecte pas mon besoin de
repos je suis dans une course folle pour
atteindre les objectifs
je crois que si je ne réussis pas je ne
vaux pas suffisamment je suis animé par
beaucoup de peurs volonté mentale ont
pris le dessus sur les landes à mont de
mon enfance alors mon corps s'est donné
beaucoup de mal pour que je me vois
enfin il faut dire que ces 17 kg il ne
passait pas inaperçu dans la glace je
comprends à ce moment
que me sacrifier n'est pas juste
qu'est-ce que cela dit de moi je suis le
premier animal avec lequel je rentrerai
en relation aimer les animaux se serait
donc d'abord prendre soin de moi aimer
la nature se serait mais tout le vivant
y compris moi ma mère m'a pas un tableau
qui est accroché dans ma chambre sur
lequel il est écrit c'est toujours toi
même que tu rencontres
si c'est toujours moi même que je
rencontre cela veut dire que la manière
dont nous traitons les animaux
aujourd'hui révèle la manière dont je me
traite
quand me maltraitant je viendrai donc
nourrir la maltraitance qu'il ya sur la
planète que tout serait donc en lin
systémique
quand je dors mal que mon corps accumule
beaucoup de fatigue et que pourtant je
continue de me coucher tard comme encore
à une carence en fer et que pourtant je
continue de manger déséquilibré je ne
respecte pas mes besoins je me
maltraites quand nous enfermons des
animaux dans des lieux exigus
alors que nous savons qu'ils ont besoin
d espace pour se mouvoir
quand nous les privons de lumière
naturelle
alors que nous savons que leur organisme
besoin de soleil
nous ne respectons pas à leurs besoins
biologiques vitaux nous les maltraitons
qui a donc bien l'effet miroir entre la
manière dont je me traite et la manière
dont nous traitons les animaux
aujourd'hui ce n'est bien entendu pas le
même degré mais le processus est le même
il est très difficile de respecter un
autre individu
tant qu'on ne se respectent pas soient
souvent j'entends ce chien manque
d'intelligence ce chat ne comprend rien
ce cochon est moche
en parlant ainsi nous jugeons les
animaux et en plus sur une échelle de
critères humains ce qui n'a pas de sens
rien que dans la perception que nous en
avons nous maltraitons les animaux parmi
les formes de maltraitance que je
m'inflige il ya ce rapport de
dévalorisation et de jugement vers moi
même et ce rapport de comparaison avec
les autres et c'est le même que nous
entretenons avec l'ensemble de la nature
si nous apprenions à nous aimer tels que
nous sommes nous n'aurions plus besoin
d'eux dans un rapport de pouvoir avec
notre environnement plus je vais me
considérait plus je vais considérer
l'autre car je n'aurai plus rien à me
prouver cette nouvelle relation de
respect et de coopération envers vivant
commence d'abord en coopérant avec moi
même et en le respectant
je vous invite la prochaine fois que
vous posez une action à vous demander si
vous contribuez à l'avantagé de
bienveillance ou de maltraitance dans le
monde
c'est toujours toi même que tu
rencontres
aujourd'hui je travaille à mon compte
sur la relation être humain animal
je propose en mode travail un
accompagnement des deux partenaires de
la relation je contribue à ce que la
relation entre un animal et son gardien
soit harmonieuse et équilibrée à
l'écouté des besoins de chacun jette les
humains à sortir d'un système
hiérarchique humain animal et a passé un
système coopératif et respectueux de
toute vie et cela commence par
l'utilisation des mots avez vous
remarqué que nous disons posséder un
animal comme nous possédons une voiture
une maison mais le vivant ne nous
appartient pas nous sommes là pour vous
accompagner mutuellement
j'ai donc depuis quelques années
supprimer les mots m est propriétaire de
mon vocabulaire pour les remplacer par
le mot gardien d'un animal pourquoi
parce qu'être un m c'est dans un rapport
de domination soumission s'est trouvé ma
sécurité dans le pouvoir que
j'entretiens avec l'autre que ce soit
mon partenaire
mes amis mes collègues et bien sûr avec
mes animaux être un gardien c'est
protéger et prendre soin des animaux
avec lesquels je suis en lien c'est à
dire répond du mieux possible besoin des
espèces dont j'ai la responsabilité et
quant aux espèces sauvages c'est leur
laisser les écosystèmes en bon état pour
qu'elle puisse répondre à leurs besoins
vitaux être un gardien s'être
suffisamment en sécurité intérieure pour
permettre à l'autre d'être
à travers ma connexion intuitive avec
leur animal jeu permet aux personnes de
savoir quels sont les envies les besoins
les états émotionnels et physiques de
celui-ci et jeu permet aux personnes de
se voir dans le miroir
il n'y a pas de hasard dans l'animal qui
nous accompagnent c'est un autre nous
que nous rencontrons c'est toujours toi
même que tu rencontres un jour je
réalise une consultation pour une chaîne
qui montre un comportement apathique
dépressif je perçois que beaucoup
d'attentes ont été posés sur elle d'être
un bon chien non seulement parce
qu'elles étaient offerts en cadeau mais
aussi parce qu'elle vient d'un élevage
de race elle un comportement très
disciplinés très cadré un besoin énorme
de faire plaisir et donc une part du
rejet en parallèle je reçois chez sa
gardienne que celle ci a été élevé avec
les injonctions soit parfaite ses
plaisirs qu'elle se devait d'être une
bonne fille pour surtout ne pas décevoir
sa mère
cette femme aujourd'hui à une vitre et
discipline très cadré très rangée elle
s'impose beaucoup de principes et de
règles
en fait elle n'est pas heureuse il ya
donc un effet miroir entre le vécu et
des attentes posé sur la chaîne et le
vécu et les attentes posé sur la
gardienne durant son enfance
la lecture du comportement d'achêne à
travers ma connexion intuitive avec
celle ci a permis à la gardienne de se
voir depuis qu'elle a pris conscience de
son besoin de plus de fun et de prise de
risque dans sa vie sa chaîne s'est
métamorphosée elle est joyeuse elle
demande des balades du jeu j'ai un autre
cas vous raconter il s'agit d'un chat
qui fait du marquage urinaire plusieurs
fois par jour le vétérinaire ne trouve
aucune explication d'ordre physique en
me connectant au chat je reçois les
informations suivantes sagardian ne
prend pas sa place dans sa relation aux
autres
elle se met à leur service et oublié de
prendre soin d'elle et ça c'était parce
qu'enfant elle ne recevait des signes de
reconnaissance de ses parents que
lorsqu'elle se rendait utile
elles se sont donc seulement et dès lors
quand elle apporte son aide
quitte à faire passer l'autre avant elle
son chat à travers son comportement
marquage souhaite lui montrer qu'il est
temps qu'elle s'occupe de son propre
territoire
lorsque je colle luminy que ces éléments
à la gardienne celle ci comprend alors
pourquoi son chat se comporte ainsi
il lui parle de ce qu'elle a à faire
dans sa vie plusieurs jours après la
consultation
cette femme recontacte pour m'apprendre
que son chat complètement arrêté le
comportement de marquage et qu'en plus
elle a pris un rendez vous pour un
thérapeute avec elle même vous le voyez
les animaux sont les révélateurs de nos
peurs de nos maux et de nos croyances
limitantes être un gardien
si donc encore une fois aussi prendre
soin de soi parce que cela impacte notre
animal que vous le vouliez ou non votre
quotidien est intimement lié à celui des
animaux que ce soit avec l'animal avec
lequel vous vivez avec celui dont vous
croiser le chemin ou encore avec
l'animal qui est dans votre assiette
souvent me dit les animaux c'est bien
gentil mais tu ferais mieux s'occuper
des êtres humains qui meurt et qui
souffre à cela je réponds ce n'est pas
l'un ou l'autre c'est l'un et l'autre
c'est parce que nous opposons les êtres
humains et la nature que nous sommes
aujourd'hui face à une crise
environnementale mondiale
j'ai deux ans je canine le canard je lui
parle je ne fais pas de différence entre
lui et moi je lève les yeux je vous
regarde et je vous demande qui es tu toi
un mètre ou un gardien
[Applaudissements]